this is a production of Cornell
University I'm all miked up a ready to
go thank you very much for the
introduction she made my research sound
really incredibly exciting I'm gonna
talk about none of that today of course
I'm just going to talk mostly about the
micro portal but I'm more than happy to
talk with anyone afterwards about my
research thank you again for inviting me
today and let's get started okay so
before I introduce the Michael portal
that runs in symbiote 2 software I kind
of want to give you a little bit of
background about how we got from point A
to point B from from there to here and
basically there was eight or ten of us
mycologist sitting around a bar after a
meeting wondering all this data that we
have in our collections how are we gonna
get that off of the labels and into a
digital format where it's somewhat
useful for the general public and for
each other researchers to use right and
I guess I'll spoil spoil this story and
say well fast-forward to today and we're
pretty much there so we've done it
unlike unlike the some of the botanists
that have a long way to go because
there's a lot more plant specimens or
the entomologist that have a lot more
insects to digitize regarding to fungi
pretty much I could say with some
confidence about it 95 maybe closer to
99% of all the herbarium fungal
specimens in Hungaria throughout the US
have now been digitized and is available
here on the micro portal so you can
imagine you know vast amounts of
information here on this label data and
we need to get it out there so people
can use it and and correct it
sometimes all this label data isn't
exactly correct so we find a lot of
things in small large packets in boxes
and then in these X okati sets as well
that's pretty much hidden you know in
some backroom or even off campus and in
some location where it's not all that
accessible excuse me
and there's various ways to get this
information off of the label and into a
computer
if anyone's familiar with some of the
global plants initiative from years ago
they're there they had a large grant
which is pretty much you know 100
percent success rate you just asked him
to go and digitize type specimens so
most of the plant and fungal type
specimens are done thanks to GPI and
they use these really large
high-resolution scanners which is fine
but they're very slow and you're not
gonna be able to do many of those an
hour so the digitisation projects at NSF
have recently funded pretty much rely on
similar protocols to use camera systems
and we're looking at a rate of 40 to 50
per per hour so you know close to one
per minute taking pictures these label
data really really quickly this is kind
of the old time way of doing it
you got your undergrad there with his
headphones on listen some sort of music
or whatever and basically just
keystroking all of this data in I know
NSF likes to fund projects that are
transformative right they want something
that's really really the next generation
thing but when all this is said and done
even if you take these pictures and you
use OCR optical character recognition
along with natural process natural
language processing in the end what we
found based on side-to-side studies is
good old-fashioned keystroking is really
kind of the way to do it even though
there's a lot of these new and
innovative techniques which are which
are very cool but sometimes just sitting
here doing it like this is is the way to
go so some of you may be familiar with
some of these different collection
management systems the different
software's you may have heard of arctos
was this which has kind of invented more
for museums and a lot of the vertebrate
people use it kmu is for those
institutions with lots of money like the
Field Museum in New York Botanical
Garden it's quite expensive hype
software good old FileMaker Pro or
Microsoft Access err or Excel there's a
paradox kind of a government one and
then specify in symbiote oh or two of
the larger ones it's kind of out there
now that most most collections are using
biological collections are using too
manage their herbarium collections or
whatever
entomology collections so today I'm
going to be talking about symbiotes a--
because that's what the micro portal
runs and is this some biota software so
what is symbiote a-- it does a lot of
things that a lot of the other
software's do although it does some
things really well that others others
don't so it's first and foremost a
specimen search engine that's out there
on online online portals it serves a lot
of different floristic data through
specimen checklists and surveys it has
built-in identification keys it has this
massive image library you can produce
different types of distribution maps
which I'm going to show later in my talk
today you can produce descriptions it
has a host of other different taxonomic
information you have the ability to
enter genetic data and link that data to
and from GenBank which I'm going to show
you later in my talk as well and one of
the more powerful things is it's a data
aggregator so we can actually go to gif
and we can download other collections
and and upload those into the micro
portal so we actually aggregate
everything into one place which is
really one of the nice features of
symbiote is being able to aggregate all
of this data and you have one place to
go and search for it so somebody on a
software for for those techies out there
in the audience
it runs on PHP it has a my central
database in the background the
developers made it completely
open-source so it can really never be
licensed and sold down the road it has
to remain open source it's a modular
system where they have different
specimens floristic and identification
modules that you can kind of plug plug
in to these different portals so there
is some customization if you so choose
it's quite vast and a lot of people have
bought into symbiote ax
so there's 43 portals as of today
serving somewhere around 37 million
records in total and if you read the
names of a lot of these you'll see that
they're either regional type portals so
for example Intermountain region of
plants they're in the herbarium Network
or there are more taxon specific type
portals so you can imagine like the
macroalgae herbarium what it contains
Leppa
you know there's that's where your
butterflies are going to end up going
and of course the mycology collections
portal that's where we're the fungi go
except for lichens because the lichen
ologist wanted to have their own portal
so there's there's also a lichen portal
as well and there is some talk about
combining these down the road because as
we all know lichens really are fungi
anyway there's just a few key symbiote
two websites if you want to check out
more information there is a home page
all the code is at a github repository
so that's where all the open source code
is any developers or programmers can
come in and change the code as they like
and you know then those changes you are
accepted and and put into future
versions of the code there is a single
publication that came out several years
ago that explains kind of what's embed
it does we do have a Google group
support group which is quite nice if
anyone has the questions hey how do I do
this they just email the group and then
there's always people out there to
answer it I'm co-chair of the sim biota
working group that hosts webinars from
time to time so you can go to the I dig
bio website and look at our wiki page
here for this embedded working group to
kind of learn more we do have different
webinar series all of these have been
taped so you can always go back and
listen to these webinars most of them
are about 30 minutes to 45 minutes long
and and we talk about a certain subject
on how to use some biota so there's a
lot of resources out there just for
those not familiar with I dig bio that's
kind of the hub from NSF I'll talk a
little bit about that later that's kind
of the realm down at University of
Florida where Larry Page was the head of
that for several years and that's what
sort of organized all of this
digitisation project in the United
States so we do have a mission statement
from the mycology collections portal the
idea is to provide an immense resource
for eighteen mycological research and
education by connecting this information
generated from its user community to
educate educators and researchers
thought it's network so that's our
primary focus is really what we're
trying to do is is get the data all into
one place so researchers can use it
especially grad students so for example
if you're working on by Polaris and you
want to know where all the by Polaris
are in herbaria if you want to go and
study those five six years ago you had
to go to each individual harbouring
website you could do that a hundred
times and do a hundred searches if you
you know really had nothing better to do
with your time now thanks to the micro
portal I'm proud to say you can go to
one resource and find where all these
collections are I'm just with a single
search and that's really the whole point
of aggregating all of this data together
so our homepage for the mycology
collections portal we have this fun
little fungus of the day here if you you
know you want to test out your taxonomic
skills you can go and and take a look at
that excuse me as different images of
fungi get loaded up we have this nice
little slideshow that kind of displays
different fungi and then of course all
the regular tabs I'm not going to take
you through and show you everything how
to use how to use it in micro portal but
just some of the highlights down here of
what we do it is it does user controlled
we have permissions for each of the
different collections in here and you
can be a data editor or an administrator
giving you different permissions and
rights to go on and use it the general
public you don't need any of these any
user logins so don't worry about another
username and another password you can
just go on and use the public interface
and that's primarily what I'll be
showing today a lot of the public
interface for people so how did this
thing all get started well for those not
familiar with the NSF program a BBC it's
stands for advancing digitisation and
biological collections and Dennis F did
something a little bit unprecedented
other than neon they typically do not
fund large programs for more than five
years in this case they decided to put
in a hundred million dollars into the
pot over a 10-year period and that's
what came about of all these different
digitization projects and they typically
find somewhere between two to four of
these multi-million dollar grants each
year starting in 2010 was the first
round of funding so the mica
mycology collections portal started out
with a macro fungi collections
consortium led by Barbara Tears here at
the New York
garden along with lots of help from
Scott Bates who's up at Purdue Northwest
Indiana and the first grant to help fund
the micro portal was a three million
dollar grant which ran from 2011 to 2015
as the name implies it was pretty much
directed at macro fungi and then we
lined up a large group of micro fungal
experts and everyone took a step back
and except for me so unfortunately
that's another way of saying and I step
forward I don't know how many people get
that joke but I was pretty much it no
one else really volunteered to head up
this thing so I decided to go ahead and
write the next logical piece to the
puzzle was to do the micro fungi on
collections consortium and basically I I
told everyone in the network look we did
all the macro fungi lichens have their
own grant and they they digitize the
lichens let's just clean up everything
else that you have left it's a fungus
right and most of them were micro fungi
and slime molds and pretty much anything
else in your funghi reom you need to go
ahead and digitize and finish it off and
that's that's pretty much what we ended
up doing as Kathy stated we have 38
different institutions involved in this
I'm not sure how many of you have ever
put 30 api's or I should say cats into a
room and then tried to hurt him in one
direction I think at the end I counted
up it was just for fun it was like over
2,000 emails and about 300 different
phone calls to get this all together
because we had 22 budgets 22 biosketches
22 current and pending support 22
previous innocent you know if anyone's
wrote in a subgrant lately you know how
many pieces are well multiply that by 22
with the sub Awards it was quite a large
network and I will never ever do it
again
but but it was fun it was fun is fun
while it lasted it was just a large
large project so we got another three
million dollars which ran from 2015 this
should probably say 2020 we just got our
no another second year no-cost extension
ran for another year funding we have a
little bit of funding left to kind of
finish up the project so six million
dollars does help right to get things
accomplished and and that
what we can thank UNICEF for you know
forgetting a lot of this stuff digitized
for those of you on Facebook we do
appreciate likes so if you would please
go to the micro fungi I think it's a
micro it's just microphone Jai community
on Facebook you know NSF likes numbers
and stuff so if you like us I can report
that next week in my annual report
that's gonna be do sound so we do put up
you know interesting little stories
about fungi in general this was our
first network meeting and NSF Kathy's
here in the in the front row so you know
proved that she was actually there with
us she wasn't off somewhere else goofing
around but this is our network of all of
the different contributors that came we
met in Washington DC for our kind of our
kickoff whenever we started digitizing
just to make sure we're all on the same
page and that was during one of the NSF
I dig bio summits that we have every
year to get all all of the groups
together to talk about digitisation
tricks and techniques so like I said we
had 38 participants of course it's US
taxpayer dollars so we we could only
fund people within the United States
actually give them money to digitize
their collections this was some stats
from last year where we had 171 people
in the network so quite a large network
of people 27 pis of course that don't do
a whole lot of work it's all these other
people that we rely on for the real
nitty gritty right so 22 project
managers 28 other paid staff three grad
students here's kind of the important
take-home message here is these 80
undergrad students which really gets
underrepresented we'd really don't point
that out enough or focus on that enough
is the fact that these undergrad
students are doing a bulk of the work
for us but in return our taxpayer
dollars are also going back to the
undergrads so some of them would stay
around and work two or three years on
this project and it really was a
significant financial incentive for
these students help pay off for their
loans or whatever other expenses they
had so I think that kind of goes without
saying sometimes how much of the money
was actually returned to undergrad
students helping us do the digitisation
work on this and so I just wanted to
point that out
so right now with the entire network
with the data aggregation and other
people coming on maybe once every other
month we get a request hey can I be part
of the micro portal and we add them on
to the collections so we've we've now
kind of hit the Centennial milestone
here we have a hundred institutions
within the micro portal right now
primarily throughout North America
although we are gaining more in Central
and South America and we're expanding
over into Europe and Asia as well as we
add these on so this is a list I don't
expect you to read all of these but this
is a list with all their logos of all
the different 100 institutions that we
have throughout the micro portal we
haven't divided here into those that
have specimen vouchers but you can also
serve observational data as well so we
brought in mushroom observer and I
Naturalist research grade observations
as well an observation is nothing more
than think of it as a bird count right
you you they've seen the fungus they've
taken some pictures but they haven't
accession it into a fungi reom somewhere
and actually actually put it housed it
somewhere so you can't go back and get
the specimen voucher all of these others
all the data is backed up by actual
specimen vouchers in an institution so
the really nice thing that I'm most
proud about is that 62 of these hundred
collections are live and what do we mean
by that they're using the micro portal
is a primary database at their home
institution okay so they're not using
specify or kami or FileMaker Pro or
Excel and then uploading the data that's
what these snapshots are doing actually
they're used in a different primary
database and then we just grab it
through an IP T so for example the New
Zealand not only a New Zealand culture
collection but the New Zealand PDD
herbarium both of them periodically
every few months we just go out and
click a couple buttons because
everything's in a standardized Darwin
core format we can just grab their data
and it just sucks it right in the most
updated data right into the micro coil a
lot of these are smaller institutions
they really can't afford some sort of
primary database on their own so I'm
pretty happy to be able to provide the
micro portal as a service to them others
are quite large so university of
tennessee university of arizona some of
these really large institutions are
they're using the micro portals or
primary data so when people ask me about
sustainability I kind of jokingly say
we're like the banks we're too big to
fail now right we we pretty much have to
keep going because 62 of these
institutions throughout the US and
Canada are using the micro portal as
their primary database so that that's
what they upload to not upload that's
where they enter their data every day so
as I said it's a large network we had to
have a large management team to run all
of this so we had various data curators
we had Teresita until Kathy came along
and headhunted her and brought her here
to to Cornell so you know you could
train up good people and then they leave
that's just the way life works sometimes
but we still have a biological
information that helps with a lot of the
background you know data networking and
a lot of the background tools that I
don't understand the computerization of
it Scott's still hanging on as a project
consultant helping us out of various
different undergraduate students and a
retired emeritus professor Lee Crane
who's really a exa kotti and
nomenclatural expert and as we speak
right now he is sitting in the Plant
Pathology herbarium working on your very
own ex okati
right now so we drove out here from
Illinois and I brought him along because
he wanted to visit Cornell so he's
helping you guys right now I wouldn't
let him come to my talk I told him you
had to keep working out there so but
he's working on your ex okati in the
Plant Pathology herbarium and going over
a lot of those so so it's great to have
him along as an expert help with a lot
of various aspects of this of this
project we have a lot of resources in
English and thanks to Teresita also in
Spanish as well so all of these have
been translated if anyone wants to go on
and and read sort of quick these very
quick how-to guides on how to upload
data how to deal with ex okati
how to make a checklist and also linking
data between sim biota and GenBank
things like this they're very simple
there's not a lot of words we wanted to
make it very pictorial you know it's
kind of like when you get that bicycle
for your kids for Christmas and you have
that quick how-to guide you don't want
to read the big manual on everything you
just want to read and get up and running
so a lot of these are
only one or two pages with a lot of
arrows say and go here go there and and
screenshots pointing it out with not a
lot of verbiage and there to read so
it's it's quite easy to get up and
running quite quick on learning how to
use the software and entering the data
so at last count we're also very proud
to say we've got four point five million
records in the micro portal right now of
these over four million are tied to
specimen vouchers and the other half a
million are the observations that I had
talked about earlier we're not bad with
about 50% geo-reference so more so far
so this allows us to do ask a whole lot
of questions right once you get
geo-coordinates
you can put a dot on a map but you can
ask a lot of questions about invasive
species movement and distribution maps
where they occur things like this of
these 4.5 million I also want to include
or just say that we have over a hundred
fifteen thousand type specimens
representing forty five thousand taxa
that are actually type type taxa in
there and a last count this only started
in 2012 the micro portal but we now have
46 peer-reviewed citations so we have
these actual not just something
mentioned on Facebook but actually
peer-reviewed journal publications that
have went to the micro portal used our
data and cited us so that's really
exciting so again lots of collections
you can click on any one of these
collections and pull up all of the data
on it right so a lot of this comes from
index for Barry Orem if the collections
in there so this is Cornell or Cup is
your acronym if you didn't know that it
tells you who the contact is you can go
to the home page to learn more about
that herbarium what the collection type
is and then a little bit about the
collection statistics how many this is
in there and how many is to your
reference etc things like that so we've
been hoping Cornell out also with some
of the geo referencing and we're sitting
on about 46,000 more records that have
been matched to your reference that
hopefully we'll add in the next week or
two to Cornell so as we finish up our
collections we help other collections
get geo-referenced and and get their
data up and online so so I'm just going
to show you come to the public search
interface here with some examples
there's a lot of specimen records or
some specimen records out there called
Cornell woods so we look at the we type
that in locality and you kind of just
hit search over here and find out that
we're there's 48 records and obviously a
lot of them come from are in Cornell
University right those specimens have
been deposited there but maybe a little
bit surprising is there's a bunch of
other institutions that have your
specimens in their institutions right
including New York Botanical Garden
courtland's not a big surprise BPI but
Arizona Berkeley Washington State
Michigan Georgia these other other
people have have come to Cornell woods
whatever that means and they've
collected specimens and put them in
their in their accession of mint or
their herbaria what we have is a couple
different taxonomic source or I in the
background so one of the one of the
ideas behind Mike mycology collections
portals we didn't want to be GenBank we
don't want to duplicate what they do we
don't also want to be indexed on Gorem
or michael banck we don't want to be a
taxonomic thesaurus constantly changing
names so what we do is just bring it in
these packs I make this or I and you can
switch between index phone gormer
michael banck
because their taxonomic thesauri they
give you slightly different results
right slightly different names and you
can you can choose your text I'll make
the source of choice but you can select
michael banck which is the default one
and you come up with 48 different tax
and you kind of get a species list of
all of those that occur at Cornell for
now woods just by clicking the species
list tab over there and now I'm going to
digress a little bit and just talk a
little bit about the spatial module yeah
this was developed over the last couple
years it's really quite exciting because
it allows you to do a lot of different
things this is one of those exciting
modules we're happy to offer it has a
whole range of visitation options with
different occurrence point Maps right so
because these things are geo-referenced
you're able to put dots on maps so you
can learn about phenology and there's
been several papers already published on
the timing of fruiting bodies because of
climate change right things are starting
to warm up faster and some of these
deadly em and it--is and these other
edible morels are starting to fruit
sooner because
climate change well we can look at a lot
of that because all the data is in one
place you can look and see how invasive
species have changed through a data
slider so every 10 years if you want to
see the movement and track the movement
of those species you can do that and
then there's a host of other things like
range math pseudo mass suit ability Maps
climate chains there's these heat maps
down here and it's really useful for
outlier identification right if you got
something off in the ocean and it says
Pennsylvania well you need to go back
and look at that data and and correct
the geo coordinates so for more techie
people we offer vector and raster layers
both and you can upload your own vector
data as well in some of these different
formats and do more things so the
spatial module is quite powerful and
does there's a lot of interesting things
in the micro portal so here's the map of
cornell woods right when you geo locate
and whatever cornell woods means you'd
have these different points on the map
so you can kind of go and look and see
where these different things have been
collected obviously I said there was 48
different collections but not all of
them in geo reference so there's really
not 48 things here on the map because we
don't have geo coordinates for
everything but there's other things you
can do with the space of module that
might pertain more to the crowd I'm
talking to you the plows the plant
pathologists so you can I just googled
plasma para and I've color-coded each of
these different species based on what
the species are so you can color code
them throughout the world and
distributions based on species here's an
example from fright opera most of you
can probably guess which one is fight
off or infestans it's the one here in
bright pink right that seems to be the
most prevalent and occur throughout the
world although ironically we don't have
anything from Ireland up here right over
over in here I don't think there's
actually one from Ireland even though
it's hide off their intestines so we'll
work on that we'll try to get some
specimens of Phytophthora in there as
well I also heard that Cornell came into
a little bit of money as well recently
from the USDA grape lab so I thought I
would use this is a nice example the
black rot of grapes just googling that
taxonomic term we can kind of see the
distribution of that pathogen that
occurs on grapes through
the us these little triangles are the
observations all the circles are backed
up by a specimen voucher right so these
were just observations but we have a
large range throughout the central and
eastern part of the US of this pathogen
according to the micro portal the nice
thing too is that we actually added a
host field as well so if anyone's
familiar with Darwin core it takes about
six years to introduce a new field to
Darwin core and then and get it blessed
by all the powers that be the plant
pathologist said we're not going to wait
that long just we want a host field so I
said okay all right you're the boss
that's fine so we put a host field in
here as well so host is not really a
recognized field for whatever strange
reason and Darwin core terminology it's
not it seems quite important to me as
well as many other plant pathologists so
we added this host field and now you can
search by host so just the the common
grape here pulls up 574 different
records from a variety of different
institutions this is just anything and
everything that occurs on grapes so
again here's the host field and
throughout the world these are all the
different taxa that occur on so there's
5 over 500 records but when you select a
taxonomic thesaurus there's actually a
hundred and fifty-four tax at Ryder
species that occur that are associated
with grape in some way or shape or form
right as host you can also map these
things there's not obviously a lot of
dots on here not a lot of things that
Min georeference I showed you a Google
map before you can also map these things
in Google Earth by downloading I think
it's a KML file and then just put it in
Google Earth and you get these little
pins that stick up here another search
that I did just for fun was the host
CMAs so looking for looking at corn in
addition to the genus Fusarium we find
there's 85 records in there with the
michael banck
taxonomic thesaurus we have about 14
different species of fries areum right
including jibber illa as well so as we
get these Animorph Keely morph names
kind of linked up in the taxonomic the
source it will give it'll give those
names and all this anonomys in there
as well so we don't have to worry about
that a lot of people asked well what
name do I put down I have this name on
the label I said it doesn't matter just
put down just write the valid if as long
as it's a valid species name just put it
into the database because the taxonomic
thesaurus will figure out all this
anonomys in the background we don't have
to do that so that was that was kind of
a nice feature and again you can go and
search it using the Google Earth with
different kind of features as well so it
depends on what kind of map you want to
produce you have a variety of options to
do that so I just wanted to briefly kind
of point out that there are a bunch of
different checklists on here as well
there's we've kind of divided up into
fungi across the world historic
collections fungi in North America
there's macro fungi and different
there's a microphone guy and these are
kind of divided up based on geography so
you know countries or different groups
local and regions and different people
can use those to create their checklists
and then there's some organizations to
these different checklists so for
example if you wanted to look at the
macro fungi of North America based on
various regions mostly States we see you
know New York doesn't really have a
checklist right now no one's went on and
produced it but the closest thing was
Maine so I kind of pulled Maine up and
just show you that you know a quick
checklist of Maine for macro fungi shows
that there's somewhere around 140
families 545 genera and around 1600
different species that occur throughout
Maine so you can do things like this now
that the data is in there you can
actually find out where they occur for
your favorite region and you can imagine
you know schoolteachers if they wanted
to going out to a central part a local
park and pulling up a checklist to see
what they might find maybe not so
exciting with fungi but they can do this
again with birds or butterflies or any
of the other somebody out of portals
they all work the same because they're
all using the same code and then I'll
just briefly mention X okati we have a
very large list where we put in all the
different titles of all these different
x okati
there's 491 x okati titles in there now
most of them are populated some
institutions are the only one
in the world that have a single copy of
these ex okati sometimes like North
American fungi are quite common and you
know there might be twenty copies
throughout but we were really looking
for those rare ones so we can get all
the fungi and next kadhi put in in the
micro portal as well and we're we're
still working on some of that if you
search mica theca brasiliensis for
example that EXA kadhi
and we do have some duplicates so Brown
University and LSU both contain that EXA
kadhi they've digitized it there's a
picture up there if we just go to look
at the label picture you know at Brown
University this is kind of what we're
seeing right now is is that label data
along with the barcode okay and that's
pretty much how the digitisation
projects project worked what we would do
is take a picture we would make kind of
a skeletal record up here with maybe
just the name on here and then we'd have
the undergrads come through this is how
we got the data in and they would
transcribe the information on this into
into all of these different fields
whatever the pertinent fields were so we
have this X okati title and then the
number number ten right here and that's
how we got the data in basically by
taking a lot of pictures and doing a lot
of transcription once you have locality
data and then you can batch to your
reference and then that's where you get
your latitude and longitude filled out
here so we kind of have these different
stages okay alright so I'm just gonna
switch briefly about another module that
we developed the last year of this
project something that I'm pretty
excited about I think is pretty cool
it's called a Michael portal i TS
sequence submission tool actually we
should just say that's a ribosomal one
you can submit i TS data large subunit
data and small subunit data it's very
similar if anyone's went on and used gen
bank's online portal recently to submit
sequence data you'll know that you have
you can only submit ribosomal data
through the GenBank portal if you have
protein coding genes you still got to go
back and use bank it or sequin or
something like that but basically we
started thinking we have all of this
data in the micro portal why not just
submit all we need is a sequence right
that's really the last piece that we're
missing because what this tool does is
it grabs your user profile information
because you'd need to be a user and have
a login to submit sequences throughout
through it
and we already have all of that data we
have all of the specimen metadata
already right because that's what we've
been working towards typing in that
specimen metadata all you really need to
do is paste in your sequence and then
send that to GenBank it seems silly to
type all that information in the second
time and this was one of the primary
emphasis is why we decided to go and do
this is I did some searches in GenBank
last year for what they call source
modifiers that's basically the specimen
another word for specimen metadata but
GenBank refers to two source modifiers
they're seldom populated in GenBank
right so we can look at all these
different primary source modifiers for
all these different groups and it
doesn't really matter if you're a
mycologist or an entomologist or
botanist or a zoologist we all do a very
poor job at populating our specimen
metadata that's tied to sequences right
so picking on the entomologist and
picking on the botanist here a little
bit I know Kevin Nixon's in the
background and will really appreciate
this you guys are really bad
at some hitting specimen even to the
general data like specimen voucher data
only at one third of the time can you go
and figure out where the specimen what
the specimen voucher is it's tied to
that sequence right you haven't you have
no idea sure Kevin you don't even have
vouchers she just sequencing throw it
away okay
yes that's even more of a problem
exactly you can't even go back and and
recreate that again if you wanted to
because the specimen voucher does not
know of course not yet okay so you know
you can kind of look at all of this
stuff some people are better than others
the entomologist seemed to like to
populate country better than that some
of those all it just do isolation source
or or even host data but a lot of these
are near zero right on who collected it
collected by the collection date who
identified it sometimes that's really
important but we just don't really have
that data lat/long to longitude data
announced attune so so the reason the
emphasis behind creating this tool was
all of this data right here already
exists in the micro portal why not just
capture that data when you submit your
sequence and then all your source
modifiers in GenBank will be will be
populated
so I'll just very quickly kind of show
you what this tool looks like it's it's
not a training session but it grabs your
username up here the record ID so yes it
is a little cumbersome because you can't
bats emit sequences you have to do it
one at a time but a it grabs that record
ID so now it knows where all that
specimen metadata is you basically just
paste in your FASTA formatted sequence
you pick whichever one it is like I said
it's I TS LSU or Ellis or SSU some
people may do just a part of I TS and
you can choose that too this is very
analogous to what's in the GenBank
submission portal almost everyone's
doing Sanger deoxy sequencing but if
you're not if you're doing some alumina
or something else you can you can select
that you can type in your title of the
publication if you if it's published and
you can add your authors right here so
that doesn't take too long here I added
a couple or you can delete them you can
either embargo it for a year or not
embargo it it just depends on whether
you want your data released immediately
or not and then you basically just click
go and it what it does is end up
building these GenBank formatted data
sets I'm happy to say other than genius
sim biota is the only other people in
the world they can submit sequences to
GenBank you've seen a third-party
resource right and it took a lot of
meetings back and forth with the jim
bank indexers and they were saying no do
it this way do it that way so I did it
the way they liked and now they accept
this data and what you basically have is
a sequin file you download and just
email with GenBank and you have this
pretty cool file called a gif file and
this is kind of what you see is what you
get so this is what your GenBank
submission is going to end up looking
like after you submit it and they
publish it so the you have your
publication authors here that you just
put in
you have the submission author whoever
submitted that the institution all this
stuff is directly pulled from the micro
portal I'll just briefly go down here
and just say here's the specimen data
these source modifiers that I just
talked about it's all populated right
here automatically and the cool thing is
is we also developed a structured
comment what GenBank regards is this
kind of cool little extra thing for
developers and programmers but also for
collection managers as well but
what it does is give you the record ID
or a grid it also gives you a grid if we
had one which is a globally unique
identification number right so you know
exactly it only has one number in the
world that link back to that specimen it
tells you the source where it come from
if you're using a different portal that
would be populated the Institute the
catalog number which is repeated and
some other information about the
accession number but what this allows
programmers and developers to do
eventually if this gets populated enough
is they can just go on and write a
little my sequel search statement and
they can grab all your data out of
GenBank much easier if you have this
structured comment in there so it's it's
just helping to make the world a little
bit smaller hopefully as far as genetic
data goes we have these linked resources
so the identifiers where it came from
that's the GenBank accession number what
the gene is and then a URL link if you
click on that it takes you to GenBank
we're also linking back as well so we're
using this link out system to go back to
the mycology collection portal and if
you click on that for the ones that are
linked it takes you back to the public
interface here that shows all the
details about that collection this one's
at University of California Berkeley so
it's kind of a neat resource to link to
and from specimens so what do we do with
all of this data and Kathy alluded to
this a little bit earlier is a project
my colleague and I did along with all
the other we gave try to give as much
recognition to the network as we could
all the other people to help put data
into this is we created the first-ever
what we call the proto checklist but
because by no means is this a final word
that this is a checklist of North
American non like a nice fungi there are
a lot of mistakes in it but we needed
something out there right if you don't
have anything out there you can't
correct it you can't move science
doesn't move on so we we went ahead and
put that out there some of the
highlights of this paper was we looked
at over two point two million fungal
records throughout Canada u.s. and
Mexico that's how we define North
America of non like and ice fungi what
we ended up finding was out of those
records there's about forty four
thousand four hundred and eighty eight
not about that's what we found
fungal taxa in these three different
countries almost half of those
type specimens which does give some
legitimacy to the data right because if
it's a type specimen you can't really
argue about the identification it's a
type specimen so almost 22,000 of these
were actually tied to type specimens and
about 20,000 of those are macro fungi
okay so slightly more micro fungi than
macro fungi but those are just some
highlights from that paper we recently
just published one a few months ago
called the our Michel portal and if
anyone's familiar with the are package
and does statistics the bar you can now
go on and use your are your our program
to grab data out of the micro portal
they talk back and forth and you're able
to grab that data and use it in our so
again like I didn't want to recreate
GenBank or michael banck I don't want to
recreate all the statistics that are
already did for us so what we do is just
were able to serve that data at our let
you guys that are experts using our
analyze the data and as you see fit and
publish and cite the micro portal please
appreciate that all right so just to
wrap up my talk I just wanted to wanted
to mention some of the education and
outreach we're starting to get some
buy-in from different my ecology courses
this one at Michigan State and at Purdue
University Northwest where they
contacted us and say hey you know we do
a my ecology course I have the student
sequence one or two specimens and they
hundred in GenBank and yours is an ideal
resource for doing that because think
about it the students are learning
collecting techniques they're learning
Natural History the learning about
herbarium accession eeen they're
learning about Darwin core fields now
they're learning about sequencing
through Sanger sequencing they're
learning about submitting that sequences
and source modifiers through GenBank and
how to link all of this data together so
there's there's a lot of benefits to
using the micro portal in your in your
classes another thing is the North
American microflora project it's just
kind of getting kicked off there's about
a hundred different mushroom clubs
around the u.s. this is kind of one
shining example where someone's put the
data in in the proper places and linked
it up so this is a public search
interface this is your metadata I showed
you but a lot of people like to use the
the amateurs they are citizen scientists
like to use mushroom observer which is
fine
but here's the specimen residing at the
University of Arizona if you click on on
genetic data tab here you're gonna get
this with a URL to GenBank that I just
showed you so here's GenBank
here's your link back to the mycology
clicks in portal which will link back to
this page right here if you click on
mushroom observer that's a hot link
right there that hot links to mushroom
observer and from there where the
citizen scientist put up a lot of their
images that's where you can grab a lot
of these different images of the morel
that this thing has been sequenced it's
been a specimen voucher is actually
deposited all the data or most of the
specimen metadata is in GenBank and you
can go to you know a citizen science
social media thing like mushroom
observer or AI naturalist and look at
and get more information but at least
it's all tied and linked together
there's also a link here on a mushroom
observer a micro portal which will link
you back to here so you got a link back
here you got a link back there from from
GenBank so it's kind of a nifty little
way to tie all of this data together and
then last but not least I'd be remiss if
I didn't say that we actually save lives
with the microphone all right thanks to
Kathy Hodge one of your local own right
here so there's a little kind of story
here that we wrote up they had contacted
Kathy about someone that ate a mushroom
and they thought oh no it's not the
green guild la Pieta it's it's not this
thing that will just make you really
sick or they thought it was this thing
that would make you really sick sorry
she wasn't too sure so she contacted Tim
Baroni over at Courtland and they worked
together on this and Tim went on and
searched the micro portal for
chlorophyll Amol of deities the thing
that doesn't make you sick and green
here versus ammonite of i Rossa which
will make you sick and it will actually
kill you and thank God they had Kathy
and Tim working on this because the
doctors were gonna send this patient
home and just not even treat him but
though you'll get over it in a couple
days well with more data and research
they find out there's no green dots in
New York
chlorophyll them doesn't occur there
only a man died it does and that's what
it turned out to be and they ended up
saving the person's life so thank you
very much guys
thank you very much for your attendance
I know you all have in five minutes so
if as a parasite I don't have any
knowledge on that right now no I haven't
really looked at the looked at that data
I'm always interested in the next
research question and trying to think
those up sometimes that's hard to do and
then and then get the data out of the
microphone no and unfortunately I don't
really have any expertise in that area
unfortunately yeah the technology better
than P is at sitting down and keystroke
here yeah just in general I mean you you
do have a range of grads of undergrad
students you know some some would do
just 10 an hour and some would do 40 or
50 an hour but once you kind of weed out
those those ones that really are
plugging and chugging away they're just
they're really good at multitasking it
seems it compared to me I mean they can
watch a video a lot of them are watching
a video listening to listening to rock
and roll and then keystroking in all at
the same time and and by data checking
they weren't making very many mistakes
by doing all of this so I don't know I'm
not sure exactly why I think they just
have they just seem to be a little bit
better at multitasking and being able to
to focus on these things and you know
they they're growing
up with with keyboards right so they
don't I don't know they don't really
know how to write in cursive anymore
they don't do that much if you're or
type on a typewriter they're they're you
know they know how to type on on these
keyboards and they're just much better
and faster at it so we were very
impressed with how much data we were
able to get in from a large workforce of
undergrad students you know hammering
the micropore all at the same time when
you got a hundred people on there you
know you want to have a good nap or two
to support all that luckily the servers
held up at Florida some yeah yeah I
didn't talk about that there are there
were some success stories where people
were very interested in what they did
and oh I didn't know herbarium existed
you know I didn't know we had all these
specimens and they became more
interested we had a couple that actually
went on and got degrees and and you know
collection management and actually
wanted to go on and be collection
managers
so we retrained we're trying to train
the next generation of collection
managers and we we had a few of them buy
into that and and they started out as
digitizers and now now they're
full-blown collection managers at
different herbaria around the US so yeah
we do have a few success stories like
that which is great this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu